he's been a frequent guest of this
program with his work with Westwood one
radio is coverage of the NFL and that's
how we saw him at the Super Bowl looking
like he could still play and then we
heard what happened and now it's time
for him to come on the show to actually
lend us his story he is Tony Buzzelli
here on the Rich Eisen show how are you
Tony
rich thanks for having number one and
I'm doing better every day
you know I actually feel pretty good for
the most part at this time still waiting
to get cleared 100 percent I got to take
a couple tests to go in today and the
last kind of come back are my lungs just
as far as you know feeling like I could
go out and do stuff I get a little tired
quicker than usual but overall you know
I got no complaints to pay that much I'm
sitting at home and on the phone with
you that's pretty good compared to where
I was ten days ago no doubt so let's
walk through this Tony when did you
first feel something was off yeah I
think you know I think it was March 13th
or 14th tonight that Monday was a Monday
night I felt like I got like allergies
kicked in that was just you know stuffed
up nose runny nose no big deal woke up
Tuesday felt pretty much the same way
but because of kovat you know you're a
little bit more aware took my
temperature called the doctor friend of
mine and he's like listen probably just
allergies you know fever and a big deal
but I still kind of stayed at home just
to you know you know I've just you I
said the image stayed home I'll get
better I'll be all good tomorrow but I
woke up that Wednesday and felt worse
ended up having a fever and it found out
that day a friend of mine called me and
said hey listen - so you know last thing
it was Thursday Thursday before we were
around somebody who tested positive we
just tested positive earlier this week
so at that point I felt like you know I
probably got this so let me go get
tested called my doc at Mayo got tested
and then found out the following Friday
that I was positive for coronavirus and
even then
at that point you know I said I got a
minor flu no big deal
and I really thought you know being 47
years old and healthy I didn't put I
thought you know this will be a nuisance
at most and I'll be back healthy in a
few days my wife tested positive to
Walter at the same event and she was
fine no problems
she didn't even never had a fever
but I went sideways pretty quick after
that weekend and it was much more
serious than I ever imagined
Tony viselli here on the Rich Eisen show
what do you mean by sideways if you
don't mind us prying because again I
think your story certainly is you we're
47 you're healthy and you go sideways
what what is that young sideways Tony I
got I got through the weekend and I
thought I was starting to get on the
other side and feeling better and that
Monday I had a pretty good day I'm like
all right I'm almost done with this
thing and I woke up the following
Tuesday morning and I was as sick as a
dog and I could really start feeling I
was wheezing felt like my lungs were
going not you know it was harder to
breathe I wouldn't say I was gasping for
air or anything I could barely get up
ice laid around all day nothing I did
would kill the fever you know no tylenol
would knock it outside the constant
fever and said you know what he's got a
bad Tuesday night hopefully I'll get
better and I woke up Wednesday after not
sleeping barely at all and now I was
really you know I try to you know I've
been coughing was hard to catch my
breath and him I start talking my wife
about it she's like well let's call your
doctor let's call the doc and I called
him and told him when I was going
through he says you need to get to the
ER immediately and that was Wednesday a
week you know so last Wednesday know 10
days ago I guess it would be yep 11 days
ago and so I went to the ER my back see
my daughter dropped me off and I thought
rich I was going in there to get some
fluids and some meds and then I would be
back out and they go in and they take
x-rays of my chest and the pulmonologist
walked in and said you're not going
anywhere you're going to
I see you and my initial response is
like sitting like I see you I'm like I
don't want to go to the ICU and he said
you don't Joyce you're going and you
need me watch closely you need to get an
oxygen can your oxygen levels aren't
very good right now and so that started
the process of going the ICU get on a
bunch of you know the drugs you know the
malaria and malaria drugs and
antibiotics and all the different stuff
I think everyone's heard about and I was
in the hospital five days and thankfully
it went on the right direction but you
know you go and you find out you're
going to the ICU and these doctors and
medical workers are amazing people and
they're in the full protective personal
protective equipment almost hazmat suits
and everything else and they look at you
and they say hey we're going to
everything we can and we're going to
give you all the drugs we can but we
think will work but we don't know where
this thing's gonna go and at that moment
you're sitting there going you know what
do you mean you don't know what
direction this is going to go I'm 47
years old and healthy this is point
supposed to go one direction that's me
at home right now and so there's some
scary moments sitting there in the ICU
tony basella here on the Rich Eisen show
so I did at any point do you think I'm
sorry to ask you any point think this is
it Tony I mean yeah it's a great
question it's very fair question because
you're sitting in the ICU and your
family can't see it no one can see you
only people who come in are the nurses
and the doctors and they're full outfits
and so you're by yourself a lot and I
think you know I first got there or so
sick and felt so lousy I was you know I
don't know what I was thinking but I
remember the Frank was either that night
first night or the next morning and I
can't remember beyond kind of blurs
together and but I think was the next
morning and the doctor came in and my
oxygen was still not great and he says
we're going to bump you up even more
oxygen and basically said that if this
doesn't you know if this doesn't work
we're going over the next level and I
remember what that meant but I remember
him saying something about a machine and
I don't tell if he was a ventilator or
what but it was something more than I
was doing already in ICU because the
oxygen levels weren't coming up and I
remember at that moment I thought my
goodness I do not want to die in here
and that's where my mind was going and
you're wrestling with your thoughts this
can't be this can't be it and I think
that for me is really where my faith
comes into came into play have really
you know hey you know praying and asking
God to help me in this situation not
understanding why there and knowing that
I had a bunch of people praying for me
and family and friends and so you try to
comfort yourself and you can really
control your thoughts because you don't
want to go down that path and it's hard
because those thoughts come in is this
is I don't want to die by myself in the
ICU and you know there's other people
you know in this kovat ward or area
where you're you are that are not making
it and and that's where you know it gets
difficult and you just try to control
your thoughts and pray it a lot and you
I'll tell you what you get really
thankful for these amazing people
amazing that have the courage and the
strength to come help you just amazing
no they're risking their you know
exposure to this virus just amazing and
in terms of you know the science of it
what drugs you did take what your blood
type is or you know obviously the power
of prayer is significant and all of us
here at the show hearing about it we
were part of all that I mean I heard
about this and I just absolutely freaked
but in terms of the science of it what
do you think helped you turn the corner
from what you're told medically by your
doctors or so yeah it's it's a great
question I don't know I got to believe
these drugs helped and I mean I was at
the Mayo Clinic so where my doctor is I
mean the pulmonologist I was working
where these are these are amazing people
on they're brilliant and the science is
you mean they're really really smart
and I think you know this was you know
almost two weeks ago more at the
beginning stages and they were you know
they had some success with these malaria
drugs and antibiotics and that but they
were honest like we don't we're going to
wait and see but I was on it in three
days later I started feeling better and
I got there was a noticeable difference
and obviously like he said prayer and
all that is important but I think God
uses doctors to help you let's get
better and I definitely think he used
the doctors there and and their
intelligence and the science and all the
things that they have at their disposal
to help me get better so I have to
believe it helped because three days
there I felt better and I give ton of
thanks to those medical workers because
they were amazing and what are you being
told by your doctors about maybe you
having antibodies in your blood that you
could donate or something like that what
are you told about your what have you
been told medically about your your
blood and your antibodies in terms of
fighting this in the future there are
they telling you you're immune what are
they telling you about all of that
immune you know once I get through this
I'll be immune they don't know how long
because it's a new disease and then and
each virus has different characteristics
of how long you can stay immune from it
they know I'll be immune for a certain
period of time and as soon as I get the
all-clear I have to take two tests at
and I took one today
don't take if it comes back negative
I'll take another one tomorrow and it's
come back negative then I'm in the clear
of the virus and at that point I'll
donate my blood and plasma whatever else
for the antibodies for them to do
whatever they do with it and if it can
help someone great but I'll do you know
I'll give us whatever I can at that
point but I got to get to all clear
first which hopefully after two negative
tests one today I already took hopefully
the other one comes back that comes back
negative do that again tomorrow and then
I'll be ready to go get blood and and
let them do whatever they do with that
plenty of a cellie here on the Rich
Eisen show okay a few more minutes left
with Tony here okay so I
want to go back to the beginning of this
conversation where you said you you you
got a call from somebody when you
started feeling some symptoms or feeling
something that was a little off that you
weren't feeling completely healthy you
got a call from somebody saying hey we
we were exposed to somebody or we were
at an event where somebody has since
tested positive for kovat 19 a few days
before you get that call a few days
later saying hey last Thursday we were
do you recall anybody coughing on you I
mean where can you can you give us what
this event was to potentially let people
know how easy it is to get this thing
Tony it's crazy rich it's a great
question I mean I don't know because it
was a you guys think back to when this
is happening so let's say this is the
10th or 11th of March and we're at the
beginning stages of this whole Cove in
and and if you remember back then it was
like don't get around more than five
hundred people and don't shake hands and
wash your hands and do all those things
and and we were doing all that you know
we were watching where we went and we
were shaking hands and you're doing the
kind of you know the elbow bump and all
that kind of stuff you know you're
watching handy washing your hands you're
conscious of talk touching your face and
everything else and we still got it and
what they tell you know what basically
realizes maybe I got it from the
individual because we were at the same
event um maybe I got it if someone
coughed and I walked through and I
didn't realize it because this is a
virus there as they'll tell you is you
can pass before you're sick so before
you show any signs you can pass it and
or any symptoms and then there's a
percentage of people out there that will
get the virus and be asymptomatic the
entire time and never know they have it
but they can still pass it along and so
I can guess how I got it you know maybe
it was from the individual friend of
mine that got it how that individual get
it who knows a bunch of us who around
them some of us got it some didn't and
so it's really it's one of the things
that we have to be smart right now and I
think the overall message is is these
health care workers forget about
everyone else first
listen to health care people and health
care experts and what they're saying is
true they're not making this up this is
not a joke this is a serious deal and
what we need to do and you know most
people my age will be ok with it
they won't have the scary thing I went
through and if you're willing to roll
those dice for yourself that's your
business but I think it's time we think
about everyone else in the community the
elderly people with underlying health
issues and people who really can't fight
this and we gotta over this next
hopefully just this month we can get
through this it's kind of what they say
flattened occur but we can think of
everyone else in the community really be
good smart choices and get to the other
side of this as soon as possible because
it's a trust me you don't want to go
through what I went through no one else
has to but there are people doing that
right now and we said I think it's a
time to think you know not just
ourselves but our families and our
friends and the rest of the community
and your wife is fine now is she or or
asymptomatic she was tired and she lost
her taste and smell what she was ticked
about and and she but she's fine she's
tested POG
she tested negative already great she's
you know I mean she's no issues and it's
it's amazing saying we both same age
we're both healthy we both were at the
same event we both get it she has zero
issues basically outside of just fatigue
and not feeling like herself and I end
up in the ICU
um so you just don't know you don't and
that's the point right stay at home I
believe I'll give you four I mean just
like I'll give you the floor you're the
guy who's been been through you know
what and and thankfully back so I give
you the floor on the last word here Tony
yeah just be smart hey be smart listen
to me due to the health care workers are
down the experts are telling us stay
away from people don't go don't
congregate don't be around places go out
only if it's essential to get the things
you need to do and even when you do that
be smart
there asks us to wear masks now I know
it's not cool I know no one really wants
to do it wear a mask it's not going to
kill you and it might protect some
one else and protect yourself and so I
think we just have to be smart and think
of other people during this time as
you're going out and doing what you have
to do because here's the thing rich this
virus is scary
it's also scare for people out there
because they're losing jobs and are out
working and so the fastest way we can
get people back working and trying to
get this thing back on track is us being
smart right now in the short run and so
I just hope we're really smart we're
diligent and listen and take care of
each other right and if you don't mind
me adding one more thing when you say go
out with a mask do make sure that the
mask is not something that could be used
by a healthcare worker it's something
that protects you and others because the
healthcare worker you mentioned Tony
were lucky that they were full PPE gear
full personal protective equipment
you're not a lot of health care
professionals have all of that at their
disposal and and we got to make sure we
got to make sure that they have it right
no you're exactly right I mean we I mean
just go wear a scarf just something you
don't need the n95 you don't need to
write know what these health care
workers do just work basic something
covering your mouth so if you cough it's
not going everywhere and we need to be
thinking about these health care workers
because you're right I was at in there
early and talking to them these are
amazing people there they're courageous
come in and without pause take care of
people like me and they were thankful at
the time that they had the equipment
they needed too but in places like New
York in places are hit much harder they
are using the same protective equipment
way more than they should and sometimes
not having everything they need and
they're still doing the work of
protective trying to help people get
over this so you got to be smart I mean
you don't use you know the resources
these medical workers need give to them
we can wrap our face with a scarf or
something else and now be good enough
Tony thanks for the time thank God you
have the ability to do it and share it
it's such an important story for you to
tell and I appreciate you doing that
right here and I'll be staying in touch
to just check in with you and your wife
and god bless
hey rich I appreciate and thanks for all
the notes you sent before you talk
I always enjoy being on the show right
back at you Tony Boselli future
hall-of-famer thank God
hottest